chungju wanted very simple things enough
to eat everyday a chance to spend time
with her family and a boyfriend my name
is Chang yangju I'm 25 years old her
incredible story begins here in North
Korea where she was born and grew up in
the midst of a famine according to
estimates two million people in the
People's Republic have died of
malnutrition since the 1990s North Korea
followed a communist ideology with a
planned economy we had a food
distribution system but it wasn't
working in order to fill our stomachs
our mother and father would gather small
grains and mix them with lots of dried
vegetable leaves we couldn't even
imagine having rice corn was our main
source of food and even that was hard to
get with each other to gain the real
machine and I said with passionate north
Korea has Asia's second largest army the
country isolated itself from the rest of
the world in 1953 resistance to the Kim
dictatorship is forbidden the two family
listened to foreign radio in secret when
we heard all the information from
outside we began to feel that we'd been
deceived so my father decided that he
could not let his children live in a
place like that he decided to flee the
country but that meant risking death
North Korea's borders are secured with
watchtowers and barbed wire my father
escaped first and then the rest of my
family left I stayed behind I was 18 I
thought if I stayed behind like a
hostage my family would be able to
escape safely the authorities expected
my father to return home because he had
a daughter there they were always
monitoring me
if the police had known about her plan
to escape
she'd have ended up in a so-called
re-education camp drawings by former
inmates depict torture and brutality
Marzuki Darusman from indonesia
currently UN Special Rapporteur on North
Korea collects such evidence for the
moment do have to recognize that the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
continues to pose a challenge to the
international community in terms of its
continuing practice of totalitarian
repression of its people
we do have satellite imageries that
clearly corroborates the existence of
these gaps between hundred eighty to two
hundred thousand inmates I have been
incarcerated crimes against humanity
took place and continue to take place in
that country
mr. de Rougemont presents his findings
to various UN commissions at regular
intervals and just as regularly
objections are raised by North Korea's
UN representatives we would like once
again to categorically reject the
Special Rapporteur and his report on the
human rights situation in the DPRK this
Special Rapporteur and his report
constitute extreme manifestation of
politicization selectivity and double
standards and have no relevance
whatsoever with genuine human rights
jang yoonju had to wait for three years
until her family had enough money to
make her escape possible first she went
to China a risky move because the
Chinese tend to promptly return as gay
bees back to North Korea
I swam across the river a North Korean
soldier who was a border guard helped me
cross the river because my father had
bribed him when I crossed the do man
River I was in China she crossed through
Thailand before reuniting with her
family in South Korea the morning after
my arrival after I'd seen my family
again I didn't dare open my eyes I could
hear my mother cooking in the kitchen
I could hear my father's voice and my
younger brother and sister I didn't want
to open my eyes because it felt like a
dream I was afraid I would wake up from
the dream if I opened my eyes I see what
the hell thing compares to the pain of
leaving your child behind when we
arrived here people would invite us to
big Korean feasts but we couldn't enjoy
them because her daughter wasn't with us
even when I went to sleep I was Restless
and I'd get lost in nightmares at first
it wasn't easy for Chan young to find
her bearings and her new surroundings
when I started going to the gigantic
supermarkets here I didn't know how to
use the trolleys so people would look at
me strangely I learned how to use the
subway cards from my younger siblings
now I can scan my bag beep like you saw
me do today
chanyoung has since become quite
well-known in her new home of South
Korea
you know maybe exciting she often
appears on television to tell her story
and in doing so she has one aim above
all when I was in North Korea I risked
my life to listen to the radio from the
outside world I had to do it in strict
secrecy I believe there are other people
there who are also listening just the
way I did too young actually it's her
first time to the United States and so
please give up fujian she was even
invited to the US by an NGO Joo young is
a great example of the value and the
role that North Korean refugees can play
is she's helping South Korean even
international audiences understand a lot
more than we used to about North Korea
Chung Hong Xiu has begun a new life she
hopes the two Koreas will come together
one day like she and her boyfriend a
South Korean the two plan to marry in a
few months